he doesn't exist anymore he vanished
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to jolly 3 chapter 2 now I
played jolly 3 chapter 1 unexpectedly in
a compilation of five different five
nights at freddys horror games this one
is the next part in that series where
the story left off in that one under the
video tiled sister location reborn
because it seemed to be derived from
that very closely this one picks up now
the last one is good I haven't played it
before I don't have no save data don't
now the last one was good so it's kind
of if you continue to waste our
resources on finding insightful items
and already about to terminate you you
have been assigned of a whole new task
because you did horrible with your last
one and it's to gather data from the
servers or facility okay but dude I
barely survived the last one you
remember how I almost died how I got
kidnapped I was put on the conveyor belt
in that a click he's banned me my way
out of life
all right Oh what does that say love the
thumbs in of Fridays okay we're here
we're here the jolly entertainment
underground facility not sure why they
even bothered ringing in underground
facility must be hiding something
dad the signal in here is awful let's
see
oh I mean from a possible animatronic in
there yeah Oh put it on your mouth don't
do that hmm you can use your phone's
night vision here cameras flashed around
the place Oh oh good I like that very
much I like oh no oh oh this is
incredibly disorienting okay why would I
need to why would I need to hold my
breath
Oh Oh No oh this this this night-vision
sucks ass I'm just gonna say this
straight up dude this nice vision sucks
okay all right well I should be able to
go forward here right so I think I'm
going for the blue dot on my map yeah oh
no it's blocked off okay all right then
office is weird it's like man it's like
a variability of a free roam environment
but it's really well made I thought that
was like the puppet or something soon
yes so this seems a lot like sister
location again with the falling down
into uh into wherever the hell I was
going oh ah so every time I move it oh
that's no good okay all right wait do I
uh oh that oh okay all right
I hate this okay so I'm getting closer
to it it should be straight through here
and then straw no turn around okay all
right tab yeah that's a door all right I
confirmed it with night vision okay
[Music]
who's that
all right I'll go back that's mine right
he Hall Oh can't go through there so I
got to go back the way I came I suppose
this is every type of uncomfortable
every type of uncomfortable I got oh oh
I hate this I can't even describe how
much I hate it I just pure hate it
this is pitch blackness I'm kind of
wandering around the middle of nowhere
can I please go back I guess can I get
some power
please oh okay oh my name is Kevin Kevin
Johnson the white man this place
attracts criminals like some kind of
boat back and that's why we need God but
not just any gods
this place needs one of the best
security guards back and you're it booth
yourself as father requirements to be an
official night guard ability we need you
to guard this place for at least five
whole nights but it won't be easy
we've placed two deadly robot in this
facility prepare you for the real thing
and your job is simple to survive I bet
you heard that name the cost if you
failed to get these robots off your is
death
now don't worry if you pass this test
you got the bureau real security guy
with a big fat juicy paycheck every
month myself these robots yeah thank you
it look behind you you'll find a control
panel with a bunch of the jump use this
if one of the robots gain your doors
that's the only way to reactivate them
remember when used wrongly and Norma
tronics are at the doors the channel
reboot for a long time the ceiling you
from me using it you know where they are
you can use the write-up found on the
same title the Red Army boots for quite
a while so you use the camera instead
when the coast is clear
let's see the cameras man through the
air-conditioning system to go out oh
sorry
ah god damn it of such an [ __ ] oh no
oh no this is horrible this is horrible
this is horrible
why are you like Cave Johnson from
Portal ok well this is a whole new level
of Ditka tree that I've never seen
before in my entire existence I vomited
in my mouth okay so we're gonna have to
UM I guess watch out for the anima troll
mode that are gonna be coming for me and
when they get to my door that's good
radar okay I got two Z's of them there's
two Z's there they've rebooting the
system but that's not too bad so if one
of you was here but I do is that I don't
know you look like you've seen better
days I'm gonna have to get used to
clicking the oh you're close um radar
where are they oh that's bad so the
jammer is the only way to get them out
what kind of weird would why why is it
jammer the only way to go oh please how
do I know if you how do I know if he's
got my hard way
damn it Janet whoa okay is that good
did I do good Kida I must have done good
I must've done goody there they're there
they're not there oh oh he oh that's oh
no I forgot about the other one
okay so there's gotta be like okay so
he's over I don't know he just didn't
come with the jammer side how do you
like it how do i I don't know there's no
Jam there we go Wow Oh temperature why
Holly does not do any visual or audio
cues when he's at the door so it's
important to use the cameras to find oh
oh is that all
oh is that all oh that's all it's real
hot of the AC oh god damn it oh so hot I
guess I can do pre-emptive maintenance
if that's gonna help me in any capacity
but for some reason I don't think it
will hey it's almost 6 a.m. so that's
nice because the temperature is going
back down how am i how am I gonna know
humming how am I gonna know okay there
you are you're up there okay there's no
I did that that was me that was uh that
was me that was on me I did that that
was because I did that okay so they're
far away but they're not they don't seem
to be doing anything to me that only
helps me get an idea of where they are
immediately and then I can keep an eye
on I'm over here which is kind of good
but it's all divvied up into four
different areas which is so stupid Oh
nowhere to go Hey hi I'm sorry I called
you stupid oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I called you stupid I did that
that's fine
how you doing you feeling smart you
feeling handsome oh you're looking
handsome you're gonna jam the system
because it's too late anyway jam it Oh
horrifying and not just because of like
it's kind of spooky but it's cuz it's
like there's so much work what I have to
do so much work to survive Oh
every night you gather data from the
facility you have to decrypt these data
in order to advance in the next night uh
Oh might as well start with numero uno I
guess and so what that means is that the
guy who was speaking to me in the
beginning was not the same guy that whoa
look closely keep all of your doors
locked if the door becomes unlock run to
the door immediately how do I know how
do I know if it's locked you hear
breathing flash you're like oh I'm not I
don't I don't like that I don't like
that I don't like this this is not good
keep all doors lock the door becomes um
how do I know if it's locked how how do
how do I know how do I know and how do I
use the [ __ ] well I thought I I thought
I did that am I not doing it when I'm
doing oh it undoes
it's like therefore Oh No
oh that's how I know okay let's walk
that why is um why why why why
oh no it's like for except the horrible
wait find out for was horrible - oh no
okay all right okay what's over here
was that breathing I was breathing that
was the breathing oh oh this is like two
games in one and I didn't sign up for
that I didn't sign up for that at all I
signed up for one
okay let's try yeah let's see what you
got why this date is so important why do
I have to do ten of them why do I have
to do ten why all right I don't know I
don't know if this is super dangerous or
if it's difficult or if it's gonna get
easier
Oh or what have you or if I even need to
go over there and unlock it because
frankly them unlocking my door
I'd like oh wait a minute I didn't
listen for breathing oh I'm dead I'm I'm
alive alive okay okay all right so I
only need to go over there and listen
for breathing when the time comes okay
all right oh okay okay all right we're
good
that's not locked all right that was I
forgot to lock it on me
what's bizarre is that these are the
Freddy crew
it's Freddy Bonnie and foxy Freddy
Bonnie and [ __ ] it's Freddy Bonnie and
foxy so that's not too hard I just got
to be on the lookout for it didn't hear
breathing so I guess I just lock it
that's all I gotta do right if I do if I
hear Nona you're breathing and I shine
my light I bet I died maybe hey foxy
okay goodbye goodbye foxy goodbye
goodbye I see you I don't know I'm going
from the bottom up I just felt like
being different you know I thought I did
stand out from the crowd a bit everyone
always said I was a bit of a bit of a
bit of a busybody that's not the right
word for it but I was a rank-and-file
dude I just wanted to show everyone that
I had a personality what was I talking
about I think I'm good and I'm gonna
hide the tips well I hope I have more
time than it seems I do mine okay tips
are gone I'm going no protection I'm
going in raw earth we're good there okay
that's not so bad that's not so bad
it's a bit surprising it first okay hey
can you uh why oh god I should have kept
the tips up the tip said the the tip
said the lock in the sky the tip said
the lock in the sky the tip said the
lock in the sky
I missed the tips can I have the tips
back okay it's been a while since they
did anything I've got a phone call
issues feeling that they might be up to
something something now I'm gonna deeply
regret what I don't know remember what
it was what if they all go at once I'm
not gonna be able to close all the doors
at once so if multiple are open should I
preemptively do something about it
that's preemptively
Hey okay all right oh no that's not that
one Hey
okay no no no no none of that none of
that i preemptively doodled the other
one but it didn't do anything it did it
anyway it doodles it anyway why did it
did let wide it is it'll end
don't dental it no breathing I didn't
hear no breathing and no breathing means
no body and if no body no breathing then
I'm gonna be fine okay all right and
chomsky all right I'll just slip out the
door that there all seem to be defending
and also I got oh an intern log I'm not
gonna really think about the fact that
the Freddie was in a bathroom coming up
the drainpipe trying to get to me okay
just started working here and I'm
already seeing things that other people
aren't seeing one time I was just
looking through the cameras and each
time I saw an animatronic something just
appears in front of me looking back or
looking at a camera that didn't have
anything in it even to make it go away
for a little while least why am I doing
this
yeah good question so that kind of plays
into what was happening last time when
phantom chica and phantom Freddy would
pop up in the in the camera okay that
was night one that was a doozy knows a
doozy I still don't even understand how
the main game works and then I had to
learn the night game huh even farther
day oh my god
okay thank you still don't fully
understand what I'm supposed to be doing
well what my responsibility is here or
why I have to be here going through this
protocol oh why is this darkness what
does my friend have to say about this
why isn't my friend telling me anything
that I need to do oh I had no time are
you kidding me I have no time okay how
long are you gonna be there buddy okay
thank you
for that I guess oh how long oh god is
broken do I have tup oh my god can you
oh there's gonna give me a seizure
camera is that what I need a fixer is
this gonna be like this forever now oh
it's coming back slowly oh my god that's
insanity you're gonna do that to me but
I'm I didn't even know what was
happening
are you wait oh no oh my god
oh my god don't do that again because
I'm not ready for that [ __ ] okay
ba ba ba ba ba I'm just like um I'm just
like um we're oh [ __ ] he's Gavin's just
gonna do this
probably not the best idea probably a
bad idea very bad I shouldn't have done
that
I am the I'm gonna die okay I'm on a
diet okay well my jammer is now out of
commission for a good long time and I
don't know what to do about that oh
great okay and my camera's out how in
the hell how the hell is anyone gonna be
able to beat this on the hell my good
god
there's no baby boy get my blood on the
ground oh boy mother [ __ ] well that's
super unfortunate for me trying to just
make a living as a security guard and
then everything goes to [ __ ] so I won't
be able to see them in my doorway is
that what I'm supposed to get at how's
that work how's that supposed to work
how am I not supposed to be able to see
them when they're getting in my frickin
doorway cuz that seems like some pretty
important [ __ ] to know I'm gonna just
radar them okay I don't know why that is
but you're way over there so frankly
that's okay with me I'm just gonna do
some maintenance
hopefully these don't break because in
the last game doing this preemptively oh
look it broke already can't believe that
yo yo yo okay so I think that oh hi you
are really close I uh Oh what what what
what is YY what is this what is that
just gonna hit that then that's whoa Lex
nice
oh right legs okay that makes sense
I guess I um yeah oh sure let's go with
ya let's go with sure okay how in the
Frick am I supposed to be able to see
them when the and the freakin system is
uh is so oh okay it's broken
okay great right there staring right at
the camera and legs legs why legs why
are their legs their legs here
why answer me the riddle me this why are
their legs [ __ ]
why are their legs this just leg did
anybody order lag it okay Oh what is he
here he's here he's here is he
they're good
did I do good did I do good I did good
didn't I [ __ ] well I'm dead
please don't kill me hey no whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa no nothing see god damn
you
oh my god am i dead or am I not dead I'm
not dead
oh I'm dead I just wanted this is one an
answer she's helping he's there he's
he's somewhere Oh God okay great hi okay
you're still there where is the dude
okay there you okay
all right that's good I get I guess
that's good oh there he is okay that's
good yes legs dead legs are gone
okay I don't understand okay one went
away one's getting closely the one on
the left is getting closer but the one
on the right is still far enough away
from me not to really worry about so
this guy he's right there you are not
there you're right there lags again
that's interesting okay that's broken
I'm worried oh god let's do this let's
do this
how am I gonna be able to do this I
don't understand what it wants from me
Thomas was to know when they're in the
office or when they're not how is that
how is that how is that stated how do I
understand it I don't get it
I don't know I I I have no idea I'm at a
complete loss I'm at a complete loss all
right let's keep going oh boy why is it
how does it help me if some of these
screens are just pitch black that how do
I am going to die there was nothing ah I
had a flashlight
can I get my night vision back where are
you how no okay maybe maybe if they
disappear from the camera and I can't
find them I have to use the radar to see
if they're inside and that's maybe
that's my only way of knowing okay he's
right there
I can't find mr. dude man I don't know
how my a sees out I don't know where
mister dude man is so is that no I can't
he's not there he's not there he is
there
is he there or is he not there where's
he's right in my face he's invited but I
didn't even have time to reboot the
system
that's impossible
there's no way as a [ __ ] [ __ ] how
the [ __ ] well yep I think he's probably
inside
but that doesn't make sense if he was
inside and I hit the reboot why would he
be able I don't get it I don't get it I
don't [ __ ] get it what the hell is
whoa whoa that's okay you're there
you're there you're not there that I
mean you're inside does that mean you're
inside no it does not
okay you just moved what there's no
audio Q you're still there
if he moves from there I'm guessing that
he's going to get me and that's the only
thing that I have to go on but I'm gonna
assume that because I see no other way
to predict this then this is the final
stage for him and this is a safe zone
for him right oh hey oh you are building
up big oh okay
sure that worked okay that works and the
ACS down too
that's okay because we actually thwarted
them because that is the final stage for
him and therefore the other one is in
fact the final stage Oh
oh my god okay so I gotta find him
that's that's an important thing is like
just finding getting him on camera so
that I can I can kinda like get an eye
okay he's all the way back he's up there
he's all the way back
that's pretty okay and I think that's
the bird guy okay I don't know where he
is if that's him whoa God I got it I
gotta get in a better habit of just
dropping it like immediately if I don't
then I'm just so screwed
so far so goo oh he moved okay he's
right there
I gotta assume that's the last zone for
him right so he moves he's in right
that's what I'm assuming okay that's
that's not good I'm assuming he's in
yeah he's in okay I am about to die but
it was more important to get that going
then the ventilation in my humble
opinion I think I did it
okay I'm getting the hang of this it
seemed impossible at first but now it's
starting to seem possible again let's
see oh my god I just got to be quickie
and snappy about it we got one hour left
we can totally do this so far so good
let me just double check never mind he's
inside how the [ __ ] did he get inside
[Music]
how in the [ __ ] did he go from all the
way all the way back to suddenly being
inside how envy fly he was at dois he
was at ten and then suddenly he's not at
ten and if this guy gets in there I
don't have the ability to thwart him he
is he's just gonna be in how am I
supposed to be able to deal with this
development if it wasn't like the time
how ding dong Bing bong blinks long as 6
a.m. I don't I don't get it I don't get
it I don't get it but that's okay I
don't need to get it I don't need to get
it all I gotta do is decrypt the data
get the Fricke Audi and get on with my
life this one thing to say about this
game and the guy who makes it he doesn't
believe in simple mechanics no he
believes in complicated mechanics things
of overlapping skill and accuracy and
careful observation and I don't have any
of that this is tense it's bringing back
so many memories of just like not being
able to even talk like not even be able
to flap my big fat gums and jabber on
about useless [ __ ] which is so
important to me at this juncture that's
like my thing in these games and if they
don't let me do that then Who am I I'm
nobody I'm just a nobody and then sad
just about halfway done well okay just
about halfway done is that smile getting
smiley er of the puppet over there
seconds
smile smile ear smiley or a word okay Oh
smiley or a word you didn't give me an
answer on that one an awfully quiet not
a lot of things happening I'd be more
happy things were happening oh never
mind I don't want that at all actually
I'd I've changed my mind about that I I
really in fact
that you could do a whole out of nothing
and that'd be wonderful I'd be so happy
last ones gotta throw a curveball I get
it you need to show your skills to your
friend you need to show your skills to
your friends I get it but I'm on why why
why why why did the last one
can I be done can can I can I be done
can I can I be done can I can I please
be done can i you done can I be done can
I be done recording testing long number
what today's subject to death
subject one codename jolly you can paint
one of the testing protocol activating
subject in three two one
it has been three hours since the
subject was activated and we've noticed
that it stops moving when it's monitored
by a security camera documenting results
okay that made no sense it's some kind
of formula off of pizzaria simulator
where they were doing testing on the
various animatronics maybe I don't know
trying to see if they were responding
anything or doing anything or just
testing them in general I don't know I
think I'm starting to get this but again
maybe I'm at a complete loss and I just
don't know what's happening which is
much much more likely okay no one's
gonna talk to me
I missed it when people you know
actually talk to me told me things
encouraged me
I don't know threatened me with death
I'd even take that at this point I don't
see anybody what what but dad there was
no one but there was no one in front of
me wait you buggy ass piece of [ __ ] okay
alright let's try this game maybe they
can approach from either maybe he can
approach from here too like if he gets
in from there that means that he's able
to get in maybe that's maybe he is able
to get in from there but I just like why
is this all blacked out that's not
helpful no not the oh he's gonna get
into na he's gonna kill me okay they're
both in the lower edge of those hallways
I mean can they get in oh boy
he's moving okay is he here ah okay
let's just
oh that's broke a that's [ __ ] broken
did that work did that do good did that
do Qatar did that too bad did that too
couldn't was he in he moved from where
he was so I can only assume that he was
uh coming to get me he's still there so
maybe but if he comes in then but if he
comes in then but if he comes in I'm
doomed I'm doomed after he'd smooth that
gasps OH
is he in is he in I don't have that I
don't have the ability I can't
maybe I'm doing it I have it so I'll do
it why if you're in here to be dunes it
then you should be here to be put dude
and it oh my god okay so the thing
reboots better than it does so I gotta
pay closer
oh there you are
okay you moved there you moved there
probably okay yeah that makes it okay
he's moved again does that mean he's
there or yeah he's there okay but how am
I able to determine that for truly
serious problem so key you're still
there I don't like how it just black I
don't like this oh my god there's a lot
of problems there's a lot of problems a
lot of problems he just disappeared he's
in he's in he's in there eyes eyes eyes
eyes eyes I saw eyes is that is that it
eyes I didn't know they had eyes I saw
eyes
too late on the hell oh my god I just
sat back down Wow he's like how in the
hell am I still alive I went to get a
drink and jolly does not look so fun so
if there's eyes there were eyes in the
right darkness does that mean there's
eyes in the left if if I'm tracking them
and I can't find them after they move
here I should just drop it and see if
they're in and that would make that
makes sense that give me away and that
might make sense because I was always
leaning to the right rather than the
left when the camera ah you sack of tats
don't do that don't do that might
behoove me to just do that in the
beginning the radar search because if I
if I can't find them right off the bat
then it just saves me some time
nope they're they don't exist that's
that's weird they are gone oh hey
welcome back to the world of reality I
missed you and there you are okay so
they're coming back which is good and
terrible mostly on the terrible side of
things
I don't think pre-emptive done it does
anything anymore preemptive used to be
whoa okay no eyes in the darkness I miss
I miss okay never mind uh let me just
see yeah okay so I was good it was good
okay there were no eyes in the darkness
that must be it I saw eyes I've never
seen eyes before but then again the cat
never came to get me whereas the Jolly
dude who I [ __ ] off you there all right
I'm getting the hang of this hey you
look real big there I mean that's
compliment you da [ __ ] you look real
real all hefty hefty hefty and that's a
good thing
now [ __ ] cameras dead and also the
ventilation oh good this is fine now
that I'm sorry understand the mechanic
of if okay you're there and that's fine
if you move out of there I'm gonna check
for you somewhere else
in my doorway yeah but before I do that
I'm gonna get this okay you there oh
he's not there anymore doorway I don't
see him
he must not be he's in here what the
[ __ ] this is a son of a [ __ ]
this is one of those sons of [ __ ]
this is a son of a [ __ ] how am I
supposed to know if he's not where I
[ __ ] [ __ ] or not he's not gonna play
nice and tell me when he's in my doorway
then what am I supposed to do huh what
am i as as a sweet baby boy an innocent
little me what am I supposed to do huh
what am i spied on is he in my room is
he not he's not here he must be there no
this nope there you are okay he's there
that's fine
this is darkness why
shut the [ __ ] up
he's only named three only 93 I'm trying
to understand the mechanics of it I'm
trying to understand mechanics my brain
is working overtime trying to understand
the mechanics why does it go pitch black
sometimes I don't get that it's not like
that it's not like the cameras off the
cameras not off but maybe it's doing
that calibration thing maybe it's like
that's for when they're moving I don't
know is he moving is this like him
moving is that what this is
must be right coz that's that's the only
other explanation that I've got okay
they're both had a possibility of
getting him so this is where I gotta be
real close about this ah
oh he's in he's in he's he must be in
right he must be in right right that
that was the only answer that I could
have gotten out of that he's still there
unless they just weren't there where did
you go buddy
[ __ ] did he jammer
ok I think that helped I think that was
a good thing I think I think I did that
right because it seemed like he should
have moved and he might have moved fast
so I think it's just like this is all it
is this is all it is and if this is all
it is I should be able to get this right
if I've got the mechanics down as I
think I've got them and I think I've got
them ok in quadrant runs this is the one
the immediate maybe it might be a good
thing to preemptively the quadrant that
they're not in but that risks them
coming up to the door maybe I should
have that quadrant queued up like he's
in quadrant this one good but now he's
where is he I don't know ok we're good
we're good
ok he the quadrant that they're not in
but that could get into the office from
like they're both up he's up here and
he's up he was up there where'd you go
he's or he's gone he's in he is he in I
can't find him he must be in
okay they wasn't in there just both now
out there okay so keep an eye on this
one here and do this one here uh oh [ __ ]
me
that's not die I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead this I can't it's not no boy i /
well you weren't all my god [ __ ]
it really does it's really tough but it
seems like the one on the right does
give a clue through the eyes like he has
eyes that appear in the doorway the
other guy there's no doorway there's no
eyes in here so I can only guess that is
the problem maybe like I save the radar
for every time one of them moves out of
like my important zones my risk zones if
they move out of it radar and then hope
for the best
he's close by just wasted that that I
mean it would have come back but I just
didn't want to wait for for it sorry I
just get so anxious when he pops up it
was he in here I'm gonna assume yes
I just couldn't risk it you know I just
couldn't risk it I couldn't risk it
because if it was you know I'm just
gonna be that's not good god damn it god
damn it everything's broken everything
you know I can deal with that
welp he moved he moved him of did he
move in did he move in I'm in a service
I can't tell you see how I can't tell
and if I can't tell then I'm dead and
where did he go oh where did did he go
in night
is he in he's not in he's nowhere he
doesn't exist anymore he vanished into
the night how am I supposed to beat that
if they're pulled bean [ __ ] the only
one that I have to err on the side of
caution with is the left guy the right
guy I can see in the door the left guy I
always have to hear on the caution like
so I can't guess on the right guy and
there's always a way to know so I guess
it's not so bad
still it's a bit douchey okay we're
doing better I think we're I think we're
getting in the sink of things like
things are starting to become less of a
complete and utter [ __ ] and
they're starting to get some semblance
of control here so I just got to keep
people in line and I should be able to
survive but if not then I am screwed and
you know how it is when I am screwed so
it's wheel blade we're doing doing doing
doing where did you go where the [ __ ]
did he just go where the [ __ ] where the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
um please just let me live until it's
time cuz if you don't I'm gonna be
really pissed
just let me live okay he must have like
June looming zoomed in and I don't know
how he did but he must have just phoned
in what I made it okay let's get the
business let's get the business they're
being a bit more active which is fine I
respect that I hate him to bits
I hope they die what I respect it I
respected stop with your acceleration oh
okay Oh Bonnie Oh Barney
ball Barney Barney I can't believe you
Barney so needy always wanting Papa's
attention you're not gonna get it you're
not gonna get it not this time
who the [ __ ] good God
stop just leave me alone leave me into
my porn I need to decrypt all of it okay
go back oh I'm out of here baby taking
all my data with me when you need to
worry about that listen response system
the facility's temperatures will be
turned off in three two one
it has been three hours after the second
phase has been initiated and a suitable
subject is not following a traditional
patterns one being monitored by our
cameras documenting results wait is that
important - no it's not following its
traditional patterns when being
monitored by the cameras is that is that
important should I should I keep that in
mind not monitoring them or should I
monitor them next night now that I'm
starting to understand this a bit more I
should be able to conquer this with
relative ease although it could just be
a son of a [ __ ] and decide to screw
with me the entire time and add new
variables in that I'm not ready for but
that being said I still should be
relatively okay if they decide to not be
a douche about it because the time does
go relatively quickly and these guys
don't appear right in the beginning so
maybe just maybe I might have a chance
okay he's already there sure damn it I
keep not putting the camera down when
that happens and I know that's gonna be
the Dow it also I move so fast into the
background that they can't even keep up
with me
that's how skilled I am at this game
alright so far so cool yeah now that I'm
kind of getting their idea of it it's
pretty not the worst thing that I've
ever seen except this is both going
wrong at the same time which is we are
bad think okay there pull there oh [ __ ]
hole eyes no I don't eat the radar I
need the system
oh thanks for bugging out on me buddy
all right
that should have done it I think anyway
okay no eyes there he's still there okay
good
he's not there he's there okay
he's I'm guessing he's not there anymore
let me just
well yeah I should've just done it
okay we're fine Lazard cuz oh [ __ ] oh
he's right there
he's on the way in he could go in at any
moment
oh boy that's not good huh um um ah do I
Jam I'm gonna Jam I'm a guy I don't
wanna risk it it's very uh uh it's
almost time to go I think Oh shitty
titty okay he's over there it's almost
time gimme more believe a beyblade plate
babe yes
yeah but I made through on my first try
on that one it's tough but it's not
impossible it is not impossible and I
don't think this one's gonna get any
harder it's just like I got to do it
more it's not so bad so long as they
don't have any curveballs to throw me
this is really really simple there's
nothing here that can be seen that is
gonna kill me it's just them hiding in
the bathroom exactly okay silently
hiding in the bathroom for some strange
reason you poop in very quietly in there
you're doing a stealth poop
I don't like how quiet they're being I
don't like how quiet they're being
they're not supposed to be that quiet
they're supposed to be cool
oh wait there we go now someone's
finally breathing please they're
breathing right away because in five
nights at Freddy's 4 when they would
breathe it was always a mystery of it
whether that breath was gonna start
right away and you did not have a big
window to work with if they were
actually gonna get yet oh it's bum it's
both its butt oh it's - that was -
that's not fair okay oh come on what was
the weight that was not bum yeah that
was not Bonnie that was not Bonnie
that was some golden was that chica I
might have been chica oh oh oh no that's
not good this I may have may have goofed
it I may have moved in real bad oh it
worked I think probably maybe that's
probably not gonna come back and bite me
in the ass
just like these animals behind me yeah
that was that might have been chica whoa
that was a delayed breath delayed breath
no good no bueno trying to trick me
they're trying to trick me it's not
gonna work it's not gonna work no way no
how new way
oh come on
what now there was no breathing there
was none
it was no breathing I was almost done
god damn it [ __ ] you I was I there was
no breathing there was none I was on the
last one [ __ ] you god damn it almost
there
I've been really focusing on this one
it's really easy to [ __ ] up last one
come on don't [ __ ] me don't bone me bone
me goes the dynamite okay booyakasha
let's do this protocol ready two and
three
[Music]
well I'm gonna guess that wasn't good
whatever we were hearing I'm gonna guess
was probably a bad thing my guess anyway
this is the last night last night you
know how they go with these games but
this is the last night of the story so
all I gotta do is survive and I get a
big fat paycheck because I want to be a
security guard right now I'm just an
intern so oh I love that intro though
that is a cool spiffy intro love the
sounds of it very very nice okay he's
already popping up so that's okay he's
popping up here yay he's right there oh
he's already on the move okay so he's on
the move there this guy's already on the
move there okay this guy could oh no
that was that's wrong yet no waiting
yeah
and I'm I'm uh my brains not catch no
wait oh is this is it broken or is it
not broken is it broken or is it not
broken is it broken can you just tell me
if it's broken or not and I'm gonna
check the radar yeah check the radar
okay you're there and you're there
you're fine okay okay let's see analyze
okay so you were right there ah ah okay
eyes oh my god
[Music]
okay where are you where the heck are
you
I have no idea where you are but that
guy got sent back it's Oh diamond town
right there okay how there was no way
then if that if that's the case then
it's going to be nearly impossible to do
that because I wouldn't have had
oh boy oh oh yeah he says he's there
okay
did I see eyes out of the right
apparently I did not I did I did I did I
saw eyes all right that that I did see I
was moving too quick on the flippy uh P
so I gotta be a little more jumpy or
less jumpy probably on the UH P Downey
this is gonna be a doozy there's gonna
be a doozy okay oh there oh
[Music]
okay need to maintain the ventilation
I'm gonna check the radar to see where
the other dude is just so I can catch
him later okay so he's okay he's right
he's right on my nuts oh boy he's inside
how so it does come back I think it
comes back if he gets in
all right we're still good okay
everything's good here so we we've just
got to be cognizant of both our
limitations and the lovely lovely lovely
positioning of where he is hoping to be
okay we're gonna go here we're gonna
look very quickly for this dude where
are you are you here are you're in here
aren't you you you would be wouldn't you
you will you you you you're you're Dee's
in here he's got to be that was ready
I'm late to the party don't kill me
oh my god okay that's nice okay good
he's back there great great great great
great great ye okay if he's not in this
one right here oh my god he's probably
yeah oh I saw the ice this is insanity
oh my god are you kidding me are you
kidding me did they really want night
five to be this chaotic and the answer
is obviously they did okay he's back
over there where are you okay oh well
mr. Birdman doesn't seem too happy about
my fun adventures let's see if he's no
he's not okay we're fine we're fine
we're fine
perfect maybe not fine but the radar
didn't show
Hadj god damn it he must have moved like
the second after I did the radar I
should always do the radar after I
repair something because that is gonna
give me a more definite answer because
if I knew it before then I'm not gonna
get a clear answer because everything's
gonna be too far removed from exactly
where I need to be let me get the radar
after this just in case there we go
[Music]
okay is well that's a problem if the
jammers is up after this is due yep he's
in here okay if the jammer is up that
means he's in there if he was close
which he was if it goes if it goes back
up that mean he is yeah in there which
is no good for anybody so really the
only thing I really need to do is I need
to track bumblebee little bumble butt
over there because bumble butt is the
one that actually is gonna pose a
considerable threat if I don't keep
track of them I just need to know where
he is not necessarily the other one the
other ones actually fine I can make do
he was far enough away so I'm just gonna
check for eyes after this gets done no
eyes means I got time check the radar
aha
[Music]
that's why I'm checking after ok so uh
no eyes he went away he's back to their
Oh eyes hello friend how you doing
I don't like the way you slid in slid
into my Dan's gamma check the jammer the
jammers up after this that means he's
there that's what that means
it has to mean that it would give me an
opportunity to kill somebody if they're
in there ok so that should have taken
care of both of them probably yeah oh
yeah that was him that was why is it
back up
I don't trust that even remotely I don't
trust that okay we got problems here I'm
gonna check the radar immediately after
this
that's three why are there three I don't
like the fact that you just put a third
one in there he's there but I don't know
who who was the other
why was there another I don't know what
will give me that Jesus go faster you
dick and also can you fix your goddamn
UI is a problem and it's real hot in
here okay I'm gonna hit the radar after
this no Bob I should have hit the gym I
should have hit the jammer I should have
I should have checked if the jammer was
up they were gonna give me something
there's a reason if the jammers up that
means there's someone in there because
they would not make it so that I died
cuz no jammer cuz it would be literally
impossible so I just always everything I
do
check the jammer after it once it starts
rolling because there's a third
animatronic in here and I don't even
want to know why there's a third
animatronic in here but there is a third
animatronic in here and I just need to
survive radar after this and then get
going
yep yeah
this is jammer back up it is look at
that that's fun and now it's rebooting
okay that's that's what that is
yep still rebooting okay know why and
maybe I should have checked I don't know
okay maybe it's maybe I'm not right
maybe I'm not right maybe I'm wrong
maybe I just need to be better about it
and the difficulty curve just spikes up
so hard I did the last night on my first
try and then this one is just rough raw
Rafi Rafi with with let's do the
cooldown sequence el ventilation Ella
boi radar after this search for them
okay we're okay but that doesn't mean
we're gonna be okay for long whoa
why why whoa what is that what the hell
Oh what's that because of the heat god
damn it I was just fixing that god damn
it I didn't realize that it could get
too hot and then you died that quickly
okay so like 120 is what the ceiling
okay but we add the rhythm we had the
rhythm we had the rhyme we had
everything that we needed to do
everything seemed to be in order we just
need to follow this guy I don't know
what's up with that third signature but
this guy oh yeah I'm watching him okay
he may go in from here but he's not
really facing that direction is it is it
a matter of the direction he's facing or
does that just mean like I want to
confirm with the radar yeah it's
confirmed okay
so confirm that he it's probably just
best to try that you know what I mean
okay
this bird its bird
okay ac is going down no I meant the AC
I'm gonna radar after this just in case
you might be in here yep he's in here
I got an AC as soon as it's done I gotta
be quick you gotta be quick quick quick
quick quick like money and AC okay 103
104 105 no not gonna get me today okay
he's not there the okay he's back over
there okay we're going down in temps
we're good okay crisis averted for the
time be go find him uh no not today
okay where are you where are you okay
he's here he could pop in any moment
he's on short route I just need to
survive a little bit longer let's assume
let's assume he made his way in here
[Music]
see live radar up yes I do
okay good and we have got three two one
Oh baby like clockwork still don't know
what that third radar signature was but
I am very cool I don't want to I really
don't want to I'd rather not if that's
okay with you do I have to be good too
much you need to fix it immediately or
you will die there wait um oh okay well
I can't how do I my mouse is uh oh I
can't see my mouse in the game what the
flying [ __ ] my mouse was no worky work
okay all right well seems like you know
what you're doing I got yeah I guess Oh
up the what do I do
let's turn back I guess I am kind of
confused here okay
all right let's last turn around and it
go immediately okay flash turn left okay
how about oh we can't go we can't go
forward whoa well I'm all right I guess
we're gonna go right through you then
okay that died but I don't make much
sense I'm not really understanding you
do I gotta go there and go back you're
not being very clear I'm lacking direct
in here okay so I go in here I can't go
there so let's go back and well we can't
go there apparently so I guess we go
here again and then we die yep we die
yeah we die okay what okay so there's
got to be like some way to evade him
it's obviously what it's obvious what
it's trying to get us to do so we just
gotta evade him why so do I just wait
for him to go by I passed out I didn't
breathe enough I just passed out
oh what the [ __ ] where what the [ __ ]
what
what's it what the fly what is it what
is this wait isn't this jolly one wait a
minute why I'm so confused okay that's a
problem okay um hi okay that's yeah this
is jolly one isn't it it's like or maybe
this is this is the oxygen control
facility so I guess it makes sense that
this was okay alright that's okay I I
guess it's it's a lot like the data
encryption minigames but different right
okay I'm gonna run out of power before
I'm able to get all these things fixed
I'm uh still like bugged my way into the
end game like it felt sorry for me with
how many times I failed but I still
don't fully understand pretty much
anything yeah I'm gonna run out of power
before I get enough systems up and
running oh hello
yeah I am gonna run out of power before
I get this done I don't know how you do
that
nah there goes all right well oopsy
poopsy looks like I'm dead Zee whoopsie
I'm steel we do I'm just he worried we
don't kill me well I hope I start over
there and not where I was starting over
before because this is weird
but now that I know what I'm doing maybe
it's gonna work out better for me so it
doesn't seem like there's ever ever any
time to get what I need to get yeah I'm
just gonna try to go off audio ques
alone yeah this seems to be the way to
do it if I hear the clanking that means
someone's there and you can hear
clanking sometimes in theirs can you
please just oh my god you can hear
clanking in-between someone else's
clinking I don't know why I just check
there I didn't need to
boy that was clanking yeah that was it
that was clanking before the smacking
one
the more time I can save myself in risk
the better oh [ __ ] yes sneaky sneaky
kitty sneaky kitty almost got me don't
screw me over right at the end here
don't don't do that let's check
oh [ __ ] see Oh God no come on my power
oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] come on come on
come on come on please please hit the
door hit the door hit the door oh my god
are you [ __ ] kidding me I'm just
gonna go for it don't kill me please
no yes oh let's not let's you know let's
let's not let's Oh No why why I don't
want it what are you doing what are you
doing it what do i do what do i do what
do i do I don't understand this part you
dad you've given me no information that
seems to be it that seems to be it the
breathing the breathing seems to be it
okay alright
why I was what am i doing what the [ __ ]
am i doing I'm holding my breath that
doesn't work I'm not moving I'm not
flashing what works do I gotta hold my
breath and move is that what I have to
do I do
Wow that's that's so weird
never would I have just guessed that or
not or not or not or not I don't know
this is really frustrating this is
really frustrating
I'm just trying to a whole bunch of
different things I'm just literally just
trying because I want to figure this out
and I'm trying to explore the mechanics
but it's like the results are
inconsistent
shall we he doesn't like night vision
that's for sure it's something where
either he has to move past you before
you can go but it's really inconsistent
of knowing when he's passed you I'm just
not sure
okay ah okay for those of you who are
curious its you have I'll explain it
later right no I'm not ready oh oh oh
spring-trap what are you doing here ah
well there you go
he's jolly Chapter two now there is
probably gonna be a jolly three chapter
three and this was really really good I
loved it a lot it was it was light on
the storytelling the first one had a lot
more storytelling and a lot more varied
environments I could really tell they
were trying to do something very
different they were trying to do
something very different with them this
one and I appreciate that I really
honestly do but there just was not
enough detail and if there was I missed
it or I wasn't able to know it enough so
the the deal is you are supposed to go
up to where they are once you hear their
breathing hold down shift and just wait
until it starts to fade away I'm not
sure if it's there's a way to see here
that it's like behind you but just fade
it away oh I saw my name there oh that
was super cool just fade it away and
then you move in the dress bad ending
wait what the [ __ ]
wait a minute what Envy flying fook what
the [ __ ] Oh what the hell
oh oh oh what the hell what is this oh
my goodness
what the hell nine-one-one help me oh
okay thank you
photos no photos calculator non 1 1
equals Oh browser nope
downloads ooh we got some decrypted
stuff not cuz it's corrupt corrupt
corrupt shift unto shift 3 okay
documents divorce who got divorced who
the hell alright fine then calendar
nothing that I can see okay
well that's weird I'm not gonna go back
maybe if you go back to 1986 or
something like that oh it's the logs
interesting that's super weird what's in
the extras menu I don't was there even
like alternate things that you could
have done in the game oh Jolly's not
looking so good jolly kind of got that
spring-trap thing going on there
shadow Tweety shadow Maxie rusty Bonnie
rusty chica rusty foxy rusty Freddy ins
bring trap all right boo hoo boo boo boo
oh wow oh wow dozen myself yeah yeah
don't like that mmm all right blueprints
office base jammer house Lexington
control room cargo area oh he's looking
at me yeah don't like that map unused
map oh nice Maps comparison uh-huh
underground 3d oh cool credits we
already went through that okay
so apparently there's a good ending I
don't even know how you'd get to the
good ending maybe something custom lady
would get a good ending oh no oh no well
I'm not that incredibly dedicated to try
to get that but this was good
nonetheless I really do want to say I
applaud what they were doing here it's
still I have to say there wasn't enough
detail in the walking around area to
know exactly it took a lot of finesse
and like I'm not I'm not the most
intuitive of gamer but I actually am
very good at figuring something out if I
simply apply my mind to it and this one
was just like inconsistent feedback I
knew it was something to do with the
oxygen I knew but I just didn't know
what specifically I was waiting for and
I'm sure that it said I'm sure that it
said but it didn't reinforce the concept
and even like the main game itself it
didn't properly iterate what I was
looking for I had to figure it out
myself and now I'm not opposed to that
I'm not opposed to figuring things out
myself in games it says that would be
the only criticism that I had for this
game other than that loved it very scary
very intimidating with the difficulty
really curious to see what was going on
and such good work put into the
tail of the world the environment the
trying new things I applaud those
incredibly just a little bit of user
experience like help and that would be
it but other than that this is really
good I don't know how to get the good
ending if you guys know how to get the
good ending write down in the comments
below I'll provide a link to this game
in the description if you want to play
for yourself thank you everybody so much
for watching and also remember I'm going
on tour to Amsterdam in July if you
still want a ticket get it at toured up
markiplier calm before it is too late
and if you're in Australia we are coming
to you sooner than you might think in
November we will be visiting six cities
all across Australia and one in New
Zealand so if you want to see us go to
turtle markiplier comm and check it out
for yourself links in the description
thanks again everybody and as always we
will see you in the next video
[Music]